debbo dire ragazze signore e signori non
sarà un compito facile chiudere perché
come credo che de gli scoppiettanti
meravigliosi protagonisti insomma ce la
metterò tutta
bene io vorrei semplicemente come dire
raccontare una storia da raccontare una
storia per sperare che poi alla fine di
questa serata possa essere di
ispirazione per anche per solo forse una
persona che possa realizzare i propri
sogni
io la fortuna come l'idea di aver
sognato e di sta realizzando di aver
realizzato in parte ma anche di continue
realizzare i miei sogni mi piacerebbe
che la mia esperienza entrasse in
qualcuno di voi è come dire adesso e
delle sensazioni per sviluppare il suo
sogno la sua storia da lecce al mondo
così nazionale
adesso viso un poco tecnologica contro
le di fabio beh qui c'è un po come che
funziona aspettate un attimo ma che
hanno vivamente come
tasto destro ebbene sì quello era un po
le prime immagini un po alcune
collezioni che ho fatto negli ultimi
anni questa è l'ultima sfilata di parigi
tasto destro non funziona però sinistro
bene ok
beh questa è l'ultima sfilata di parigi
noi abbiamo iniziato il mio fratello una
storia diciamo così come dire abbastanza
come molta incoscienza siamo partiti da
lecce mio fratello è andato a milano
sulla filosofia a milano appunto
e mentre faceva filosofia avevamo un
pallino di gioco che mio fratello c'è
quello di non pesare sui miei genitori
perché i miei genitori fossero delle
persone benestanti che non ci facciamo
mancare niente però c'è questo pallino
dell'indipendenza della necessità di
come dire di vivere facendo come dire
pesando su noi stessi
appunto mio fratello è andato due anni
prima
arrivato due anni primi a milano inizia
a lavorare nella moda come part time
come venditore e io sono arrivato anni
dopo da un percorso artistico fatto dice
artistico qui a lecce appunto dopo
questo percorso artistico o
sostanzialmente diciamo sono arrivato in
fatto lacrime belle altri accame belle
arti in cui mi ha dato come dire questa
esperienza sono arrivato lì
tutto sommato dalla provincia con tanta
voglia di fare con tanta voglia di
realizzare le cose
e infatti mentre studiavo mentre
studiavamo lavoravamo ci lavoravamo
perché abbiamo aperto una piccola
attività una piccola attività di camicie
facevano delle camicie molto semplici
perché volevamo vivere appunto come
dicevo prima indipendentemente da lì
abbiamo ci siamo pagato gli studi ci
siamo pagati appunto all'università ci
siamo pagati un pò tutte quelle
esperienze facevamo una vita come dire
rispetto ai nostri coetanei anche molto
più interessante però perché riuscivano
a trovare un indipendenza economica
io poi dopo gli studi su un partito non
sono partito volevo fare un'esperienza
volevo sostanzialmente diciamo la verità
non fare il militare che mio fratello
era riuscito a evitare grazie delle
conoscenze diciamo familiari in qualche
modo e io invece dovevo farlo perché
toccava a me odiavo l'idea di fare il
militare di avere come dire rientrare in
quel sistema e andai via andai via in
giappone
in realtà anteprima in india percorsi un
viaggio verso l'oriente dove dove fui
molto importante proprio perché mi
staccai in maniera come dire anche
poetica forse da quella che la realtà no
che mi aveva mm era appartenuta fino a
quel momento questo viaggio mi portò poi
in giappone in porto in giappone perché
per perché avevo nella mia famiglia
c'erano stati degli antenati diciamo che
abbiamo fatto dei commerci col giappone
ero curioso avevo letto mishima tutte
queste cose qui a 17 anni il buddismo
ero interessato a quella cultura capita
nel momento giusto capitale quando il
giappone appunto esplodeva per la sua
creatività per la sua capacità di
imporre prodotti nel mondo che erano
assolutamente innovativi bene la mia
forza ii fu di riuscire a rimanere lì
trovai un lavoro volevo lavorare nel
design
volevo disegnare automobili devo
disegnare
macchine fotografiche perché quello si
conosce del giappone
in realtà la mia passione per la moda ai
miei genitori e mia madre mio padre che
sono stai così importanti nella nel
creare come dire una condizione di
visione libera forte verso il futuro
la moda mi apparteneva perché come molti
di voi se di lecce sapete mia madre a
dei negozi ancora oggi dopo 50 anni e
questa passione venne fuori non riuscì a
comunicare con queste aziende e dovetti
andare appunto a lavorare cioè cercare
un designer la fortuna volle che mise in
contatto con questo designer giapponese
che si chiama io ci la moto che era una
star del momento a parigi grande
innovatore e fece un esperienza di
un'esperienza di rimasi lì in realtà tre
anni quasi due anni e mezzo tre anni mio
fratello nel frattempo da solo mentre
sulla filosofia diventa un ricco molto
ricco perché fece un ragazzo si chiama
romeo gigli all'epoca una società questa
società in pochi anni da zero in tre
anni raggiunsero 50 miliardi di
fatturato mio fratello aveva 24 anni ed
era appropriata della metà del marchio
vendette il marchio diventa molto molto
ricco e finanziò mi disse quando ero lì
perché non torni facciamo una cosa
insieme
infatti io questa è la storia con azione
non è la mia storia d'amore sulla mia e
di mio fratello a cui sono legato non so
come fratello ma anche proprio nella
nell'avventura di aver realizzato questo
progetto mi finanziò torna dal giappone
ero stanco avevo esaurito quella
esperienza meravigliosa tornare qui
iniziamo in maniera come dire io
incosciente perché non capivo realmente
quelli che erano i potenziale di questa
di questa di questo racconto iniziai e
niente inizio corso nazionale
in pochi anni avremo successo nel 98 e
mi spindler disse che consumo nazionale
aveva cambiato il costume come come da
ormai ha fatto nell'ottanta avevo
disegnato una nuova silhouette aveva
avvicinato al corpo in qualche modo i
vestiti avevo creato uno stile minimale
rock e rock e ancora oggi governa
diciamo l'estetica contemporanea
questo con grande endorsement perché
avremmo una crescita stratosferica ecco
qui entra mio fratello che con la sua
grande capacità di essere creativo ma
anche per azionale trova un fondo di
investimenti che si chiama 3a e poi
ritorneremo forse per voi brevemente per
capire come realizzare i propri sogni e
da lì iniziamo aprire negozi siamo
aprire negozi in tutto il mondo in
realtà noi diventano famosi perché e mi
spinger seppe della nostra diciamo
creatività attraverso gli attori di
hollywood ci scopriamo gli attori di
hollywood
questo che sto facendo vedere nel
frattempo sono le ultime campagne di
stampa questo è lo spazio di milano uno
degli spazi questioni negozi di cui
parleremo a primo dei negozi alcuni
negozi inizio alla nostra storia
sempre in crescita e appunto con carlo
che aveva già molta esperienza
facciamo questo accordo contrae triay
compro il 15 per cento ci finanzia
compro il 15 per cento della nostra
società e grazie a questo 15 per cento
che all'epoca erano 10 miliardi di lire
noi iniziamo a compra una fabbrica di
produzione appunto finanziamo le
aperture negozi e da liberamente come
dire ci fu un cambio anche proprio di
mentalità perché perché tria e ci
imponeva di essere certificati ci poneva
di essere trasparenti ci poteva di
essere profittevoli ci impone di essere
razionali e in questo senso voglio dire
questo è stata una grande input una
grande crescita forma perché ci poniamo
il problema di essere sì visionari io
ero visionario ma nello stesso tempo
concreti ecco quando il sogno raggiunge
la concretezza lì si raggiunge come dire
quello che tutti noi vogliamo
raggiungere il sogno senza concretezza
il sogno senza progetto senza
realizzazione rimane un sogno
questo aspetto secondo me spesso i
giovani non lo capiscono
spesso non c'è nella cultura
contemporanea italiana c'è solo il sogno
ma a fianco al sogno ci vuole grande
razionalità ci vuole grande visione
grande determinazione e grande
organizzazione cingolani mi ha colpito
per quello che ha detto ci vuole ordine
e l'ordine e mi ha portato a un'idea che
mio nonno mi diceva quando ero piccolo
mi diceva guarda 6 attento perché
l'ordine e ricchezza irrisorio e povertà
in realtà è proprio vero nelle aziende
proprio così l'ordine ricchezza e
povertà il mio disordine creativo viene
veniva incanalato dal mio fratello in
ordine creativo in un ordine diciamo
pragmatico che fosse un progetto
sostenibile economicamente questo ve lo
propongo come stimolo a voi giovani che
sognate che volete realizzare
ricordatevi sempre che l'ordine
ricchezza ai bisogni e povertà
ricordatevi sempre che dietro una
visione è anche la più sconclusionata la
più folle
c'è sempre qualcosa di razionale solo
così è come dire la possibilità di
crescere di nasce di vivere e di
esistere bene qui invece abbiamo alcuni
negozi abbiamo per il mondo questo
momento molto importante anche per me
perché coston azionato 25 anni sta
crescendo molto non è facile per un
brand indipendente come dire che
comunque ha subito la crisi nel 2008
ritornare a crescere quest'anno apriremo
circa otto negozi dei quali la maggior
parte nell'asia pacific dove in qualche
modo è il percorso di sviluppo
obbligatorio per il fashion italiano che
stavano per grandi risultati
poi da lì come dire una mia attitudine
anche verso verso in qualche modo
parliamo di innovazione che cos'è
l'innovazione della moda l'innovazione
la moda è un fattore di successo allora
c'è due fattori di innovazione il primo
è lo stile lo stile vuol dire fare uno
stile autentico che sia riconoscibile
che sia innovativo e quella del
minimalismo quello che diceva e mi
spinge aver creato uno stile che non
esisteva prima essere riconosciuto nel
mondo
oggi tutti poi in fondo come dire avete
un estetica che parente di quello che io
ho pensato ho sentito in quegli anni li
semplicità silhouette più vicino al
corpo quando io ho iniziato avvicinare
la sicurezza il corpo cioè non esistono
degli spalloni la modena lontana
dalla realtà io volevo questa
comunicazione con la vita vera
innovazione vuol dire anche
sperimentazione noi abbiamo sperimentato
per esempio nel 2007 abbiamo fatto
questo solo are back abbiamo fatto
questa collaborazione fra un'azienda
tedesca dopo la vedrete non bag di lusso
in cui camminando si può caricare il
cellulare la macchina fotografia tutto
questo non si è presa un po intrippato
in questo senso sono stato abbiamo
realizzato delle giacche bene questo è
un esempio ma abbiamo religione leggere
con delle frequenze laser particolare
dove siamo riusciti a fondere dei
tessuti naturali senza fibre chimiche
per cui questa è stata una grande
innovazione fatta con laboratorio
scientifico di firenze però la moda
appunto non è o non è l'innovazione di
cingolani che nel meraviglioso la moda è
un trend e la moglie una cosa molto più
sottile una cosa da molto in qualche
maniera
come dire più difficile anche qui
abbiamo news news è stato proprio ieri
sera con grande gioia candidato nel best
fra guns of the year per a dire nei 5
pro profumi più importanti al mondo che
saranno premiati a marzo l'anno prossimo
e noi che siamo una realtà comunque
piccole indipendente competiamo con
gruppi come lvmh il se loro hanno
eccetera
e questa notizia è stata di grande gioia
proprio ieri sera la camera i profondi
mondiali me l'ha comunicata proprio
perché nelle fragranze io mi spendo
personalmente cerco di essere innovativo
noi con quel profumo nero è uscito nel
debbo dire che siamo abbiamo creato una
linea infatti a che non esisteva prima
e per fare questo ci sono andata a
grasse per due settimane ha voluto
capire voluto comprendere occluso
approfondire questo è un altro aspetto
che vi tocca personalmente quando si
fanno le cose bisogna andare al fondo
bisogna dire andare al fondo del barile
bisogna aver paura bisogna toccare
quelle che sono le corde fondamentali
questa è una fragranza invece quella di
prima che è stata premiata come miglior
ragazzo player nel 2010 ecco questa è la
sola bag di cui parlavano esperimento
molto interessante anche lui
contemporanei internazioni importanti
qua invece parliamo del rapporto con le
celebrity kate moss chiaramente essere
innovativi vuol dire
anche accedere a persona innovative cioè
persone che nel loro campo fanno
innovazione e questo corto circuito crea
nella mente di un creativo
un'esaltazione della propria visione c'è
il rapporto che i creativi e qualcosa
che in qualche maniera ti alimentati
nutre chi ti fa diventare ancora più
forte ancora più visionario noi abbiamo
avuto la fortuna di collaborare credo
con i più grandi
diciamo probabilmente altissimi
esistenti come marina abramovic
insomma giada colagrande willem qui ci
abbiamo madonna c'abbiamo cameron diaz
kate moss ma questo va bene i nostri
amici leccesi che lorenzo ma questo
adesso stiamo lavorando su un altro
progetto appunto con mick per per il
nuovo tour
abbiamo lavorato un po con tutti ma
questo è importante interessante vedere
lady gaga lì che ha presentato l'ultimo
profumo a parigi interamente avessi
agosto nazionale cioè con un total look
rose nazionale questo interessante
perché presentava la sua fragranza con
come dire non è un look che secondo lei
incarna la vernita questo privilegio e
appunto come dicevo è poi il frutto ed
alimenta anche la creatività in questo
senso
qui continuiamo ancora appunto con con
bobby che va d'oro in quella in
quell'immagine ecco direi che a questo
punto secondo me il discorso diciamo
forse potremmo concludere in questo modo
cioè potremmo dire che forse oggi noi ci
dobbiamo porre un modello italiano di
innovazione è un modello italiano di
sviluppo dell'innovazione e una notizia
che ancora un conosce nessuno al fayed
che il proprietario di harrods che ha
venduto a rose l'anno scorso sta facendo
un sito dove ha mandato degli scouting
in italia per creare l'artigiano di
lusso vale a dire dei pezzi unici che
non hanno prezzo che possono costare
anche 500 mila a un milione di euro
perché credono che l'italia come prende
italia rappresenti questa capacità unica
di rappresentare l'uso che vuol dire
questo vuol dire che proprio in quella
chiave in quel cuneo fra innovazione e
tradizione fra capacità storica che solo
noi italiani abbiamo fra questo popolo
meraviglioso che ha vissuto nella
bellezza negli ultimi duemila anni e la
capacità di innovare
c'è un come dire una percezione che il
pianeta ci dà una specie di bonus e dice
guardate voi potete fare il l'eccellenza
voi potete progettare degli oggetti
meravigliose noi ve li riconosciamo
ecco questo è molto importante perché
vuol dire che c'è un territorio di
crescita straordinario in questo senso
per giovani che hanno in 20 vuol dire
recuperare vecchie tradizioni e guardare
al futuro vuol dire unire queste due
come dire questi due elementi che sono
fondamentali io stesso ancora oggi
lavoro così io stesso lavoro fondendo la
tradizione sartoriale più estrema più
artigianale più credibile con in qualche
modo la sperimentazione più assoluta
ecco se al fayed sta facendo un sito
milionario in cui investirà delle cose
pazzesche ha mandato 35 scouting per
andare a rovistare in quei laboratori di
tutte le categorie che vanno dal design
che vanno dalla produzione qualsiasi
cosa per trovare degli oggetti di
eccellenza vuol dire che noi la nostra
carta ce la dobbiamo giocare così noi
sia un paese che ha sempre fatto
l'eccellenza non possiamo seguire i
numeri grandi numeri le massimo abbiamo
i soldi una viola mentalità
ognuno di noi deve dire in qualche modo
riflettere su questo aspetto riflettere
su quella che sono i nostri punti di
forza come sistema italia riflettere su
quella che la nostra creatività
dunque io credo che dalla tecnologia al
design all'artigianato qualsiasi forma
questa prospettiva di ritirare fuori che
lui che sono i nostri valori storici sia
una fonte di grande ricchezza poco
ancora tutta da scoprire li c'e
veramente tanto da fare
certo in qualche modo come dire il mondo
reale ha bisogno di cervelli
l'università deve cambiare senza
cervelli non si costruisce l'innovazione
e qui bisogna che i giovani siano forti
siano determinati rompano degli schemi e
ho saputo noti ho letto una notizia
devastante per quanto mi riguarda
l'altro giorno mi leggerà la 5 la
seconda università in italia per quanto
riguarda le scienze e le tecnologie
la seconda dopo il politecnico di milano
oggi la cinquantesima su 51 in dieci
anni ha bruciato un capitale umano
stratosferico pazzesco perché perché
hanno vinto chi ha vinto chi è rimasto
probabilmente sto fornendo qualcuno ma
dico la verità è rimasto il nipote
l'amico il parente il cugino bisogna
romperle queste cose e voi le quote che
rompe le potete rompere soltanto le
potete rompere soltanto reclamando
meritocrazia le potete rompere soltanto
organizzando che capendo che se voi vi
organizzate potere oggi il pianeta è
pieno di soldi si dice crisi crisi crisi
è tutta una bufala
io vi assicuro che in questo momento ivo
i fondi mondiali non stanno cercando
altro che voi che idee che creatività ma
progetti veri che realizzano ricchezza
il mondo si sta distruggendo tetto
cingolani per cui sta a voi
riprogettarlo sta a voi ricrearlo con
idee che facciano profitto rispettato
rispettando questo pianeta
vi assicuro che il problema di soldi è
un finto problema se voi avrete idee
vere non ci saranno problemi soldi li
troverete perché i grandi c'è una
ricchezza del pianeta che è immensa e
che vuole intercettare idee dunque io
direi che l'innovazione diciamo
lì donazione un'attitudine secondo me è
un'attitudine e non c'è innovazione
senza perseveranza
per concludere mi piacerebbe leggervi un
piccolo paragrafo di un libro che appena
finito di scrivere un libro che mi è
stato chiesto da la mia mamma giapponese
non voglio offendere mia madre che come
dire in qualche modo mi ha creato che ha
contribuito a fare di me quello che sono
non smetterò mai di ringraziare i miei
genitori mio padre mia madre perché mi
hanno liberato mi hanno dato una mente
libera mi hanno fatto viaggiare a 15
anni a 16 anni in giro per il mondo ha
detto fai quello che vuoi sogna e
renditi libero dal mondo però io ho
vissuto questa esperienza anche con la
madre di oggi con cui ho vissuto e lecce
a 94 anni un anno fa mi ha mandato
un'email e mi ha detto e io ti prego
prima di cambiare realtà prima di andare
in un'altra dimensione mi devi
raccontare quei momenti quei momenti
particolari io l'unico ragazzo straniero
in 250 persone che erano in qualche modo
giapponesi che hanno diversi da me che
non parlavano la mia lingua
bene io ho finito questo libro con
immenso piacere proprio il 18 di agosto
adesso lo sto traducendo in giapponese
per lei non so cosa farò se lo
pubblicano però questo è un libro che
parla di quella esperienza un mondo
nuovo si chiama perché quello era un
mondo nuovo per me io atterravano un
altro pianeta
e qui c'è anche negli intermezzi invece
che parlano del presente di quello che
oggi ecco qui c'è dei piccoli questo si
chiama intermezzo è uno dei tanti
intermezzi che c'è in questo libro mi
piacerebbe concludere così sappiamo che
a volte i sognatori quando credono in
quello che fanno
vanno oltre ogni immaginazione creano
scenari mai visti
visioni che trascina nel mondo verso
nuove dimensioni tracciano fonti da cui
l'umanità si nutre i sognatori
sperimentano l'intuizione la
perseveranza la perfezione per questo
cambiano il mondo
alcune volte all'inizio è difficile
capirlo
ogni tanto sono malvisti per la loro
durezza lo stessi vita di arrivare al
risultato spesso sbagliano
ma non cambiano idea e traggono ancora
più energia da quelle difficoltà per
materializzare il loro sogno
cadono e si rialzano senza tregua perché
sono le emozioni ea muovere l'energia
potente che alimenta l'incosciente
determinazione che senza scampo li guida
con forza grazie
io purtroppo non sono cattolica non so
credete però la mia pelle si abbiamo una
grande emozione quando senti papa
wojtyla che disse non abbiate paura
non abbiate paura ragazzi non c'è da
avere paura
bisogna avere coraggio bisogna lottare
bisogna lottare per lo prevede
organizzatevi ce la farete fate molti
figli questo paese ha bisogno di sangue
fresco per continuare a esistere prezzi